in this video I want to talk a little
bit more about the electron transport
chain specifically what makes up the
chain the chain is made up of four
multi-protein complexes that you should
be familiar with or at least have some
sort of idea of so the first complex
basically we talked about how we're
reoxidized the nadh and fadh2 s well in
complex one we're starting off with with
nadh that's coming to the electron
transport chain it's ready to get
oxidized so complex one is called NADH
coenzyme q oxidoreductase that's a crazy
name and all but I'll break it down for
you just a second so complex one what
happens we have electrons going from
NADH they're flowing all the way they're
making their way towards coenzyme q
which is also called ubiquinone now why
is it called NADH co q oxidoreductase
well nadh is oxidized coenzyme q is
reduced because the electrons are going
from NADH to coenzyme q so at least well
not directly by the way I'll elaborate
more on then just a second but the
electrons are going from NADH to occur
enzyme Q eventually if you know that
much then what would you expect has the
higher reduction potential nadh or
coenzyme q if you said coenzyme q you're
correct because the electrons flow from
low to high reduction potentials so a
complex one this is essentially what
happens now what we want to do what's
the point of all these different protein
complex or yeah the protein complex is
electron transport chain
essentially what we want to do this is
very critically important I think to
take reduced electron energy and turn it
into potential energy in the form of an
electro chemical gradient
so when I mentioned this I mentioned the
the proton gradient right the proton
gradient where it the high concentration
of protons was in the intermembrane
space and the low h+ concentration was
in the matrix so what these complexes do
or what we want out of them is we want
these redox reactions to somehow cause
the the proton gradient to be
established so in this first complex we
want it we want to know if it pumps h+
protons from the matrix into the
intermembrane space so essentially if we
have h pluses here in the matrix and we
have a bunch out here in the
intermembrane space do things normally
want to go up their concentration
gradient or down if you recall they
definitely want to go down their
concentration gradient so if we want to
take these H pluses and we want to take
them from the matrix to the
intermembrane space that is called
active transport right because it's
moving against its concentration
gradient and if it's moving against this
concentration gradient its active
transport that means it's going to
require some sort of energy so complex
one it actually it actually does pump
protons so the first of all the answer
is yes to this question and how does it
actually do that well it has this this
series of redox reactions in here
actually have a negative Delta G
specifically that negative Delta G is
for at least 4 complex number one is
negative 81
qulet oops negative 81 kilojoules per
mole so that's highly exergonic and that
power is the pumping of these protons
into the intermembrane space complex 2
is called succinate coenzyme q
oxidoreductase so we expect succinate to
get oxidized and coenzyme q to get
reduced that's exactly what happens the
electrons flow from succinate to
coenzyme q if you recall succinate was
showed up in in the TCA cycle right so
we took succinate turn it in to fumarate
and it's actually what
year Section eight is being turned
infirmary and eventually those electrons
from succinate go to coenzyme q this
this enzyme here is embedded in the
inner mitochondrial membrane and this
men's i'm here is actually succinate
dehydrogenase and if you recall that's
also the thing that makes fadh2 so and
we're if you recall even further is that
let me actually write that down that
this sex in ad hydrogenase makes fadh2
we mentioned in earlier videos that
fadh2s are only worth 1.5 a TV whereas
nad ages are worth 2.5 ATP the reason
why here is that complex number two does
not pump protons into the intermembrane
space from the mitochondrial matrix so
because of this it could this fadh2
essentially it contributes less to the
productive efficiency of this process so
this is a less of a contribution to the
proton gradient right that results in
loops fadh2 being worth less ATP then
nadh in this process here you'll notice
is actually much less exergonic than
this complex number one complex number
two it is still extra garlic but it's
only it only releases thirteen point
five kilojoules per mole so this is a
key idea that we'll probably talk about
in other videos as well complex number
three the enzymes are flowing from
coenzyme q decided chrome c it's called
co qh2 cytochrome oxidase what's with
the crazy name and why does coke coke
you have an h2 on it here the reason why
is because at this point it's been
reduced right this this coenzyme q was
Joost by this nadh ultimately and when
it's reduced it gains hydrogen so this
is the reduced form of coenzyme q but
coenzyme q now is going to get oxidized
and cytochrome c is going to be reduced
and so this that's what actually happens
at this complex and this complex is it
free energy changes negative 34 point 2
kilojoules per mole and does it pump
protons the answer here is yes matter of
fact all the complexes except complex to
pump protons
humbugs 4 also pumps protons and it's
just called cytochrome oxidase why is
this one have such a simple name what is
the last complex this is a complex
number for the electrons are going from
cytochrome c from from the previous
complex over to oxygen so basically
oxygen is just oxidizing cytochrome
cytochrome c so in this last process we
get we have oxygen being turned into
water and this is actually highly highly
exergonic it weighs 110 kilojoules per
mole reaction now all three of these
complexes 1 3 & 4 they all contribute to
this this grading that we're
establishing here which is very very
important because we're taking the the
reduced electron energy of NADH and even
fadh2 and turning that into this
electrochemical gradient now once we
build a high concentration of H pluses
around here in this inter membrane space
those H pluses want to get back into the
matrix but they can't unless they travel
through a particular ion channel that's
called ATP synthase which we'll talk
about later but you should recall that
things flowing down their concentration
gradient is a spontaneous process so
essentially once we use we use the
spontaneous series of redox reactions to
power the production of this
electrochemical gradient now once this
electrochemical really wants see the H
pluses begin to flow back down the
gradient that's going to release energy
we're going to use and harness that
energy to produce ATP specifically ATP
synthase is the enzyme that does that
what's like
about that later so what let the chain
itself what do I keep getting all these
sort of you know simple ideas as far as
descriptions of electron transport chain
what does it actually look like well
this is it but what's going on here I do
this little key here to kind of keep
things as simple as possible anything
written in this green color here is
complex ones that would include
these things here complex two is written
in this light blue here complex three is
in gray and this complex complex 4 is in
this lime green here any red arrows
indicate a reduction reaction and any
blue arrows indicate an oxidation
reaction anything also written in white
is not really part of the part of a
complex as sort of like a what's it
called nadh and nad+ it's sort of part
of complex one but it's not really all a
part of complex one kokyu here is notice
it's it's written in yellow that's
because it kind of takes things and is
involved with more than just one complex
same thing as with cytochrome c here
it's kind of in between complexes 3 & 4
where and then coenzyme q is between 2 1
& 3 so it's kind of a mess so that's not
all too important anyway what's going on
here
so nadh needs to get reoxidized so it
comes in here and starts off the chain
so NADH is oxidized hence this blue
arrow here but when it's oxidized
something else is reduced
what is reduced FMN FMN is a protein
right that will accept the electrons and
the protons from NADH so NADH is giving
up its protons and its electrons to FMN
at the manual notice becomes this FMN h2
so that the fact that it picked up those
H's means that it was reduced so now
it's carrying those electrons and those
those protons now it is going to be
oxidized back into FMN and when it is
it's going to give those where the
electrons going they're going to this
iron sulfur cluster here so notice here
we have F MN
and FES ox which is an oxidized form of
the iron sulfur cluster so here what
happens is the FM NH 2 gives up its
protons and its electrons to this iron
sulfur cluster but and so the iron
sulfur cluster gets reduced but notice
that it doesn't have these H's attached
to it the reason why is because those
H's cannot be accepted by this iron
sulfur cluster iron sulfur clusters let
me note this here iron sulfur clusters
can not accept protons so those protons
are actually dumped into the nearest
hydrophilic space which in many cases is
the the intermembrane space side right
so essentially what's going on here is
that the electrons are being passed in
in this chain in this order going from
left to right so if I asked you the
question of between cytochrome C and F
MN which has the higher reduction
potential what would you say the answer
would be cytochrome C because it's
further down in the chain so it's it
would be able to take electrons from
anything the cytochrome C right would be
able to take electrons away from
anything that comes before it
and then F MN for instance would be able
to give electrons to anything that comes
after it so one thing that I do want to
mention though is this this complex to
here it doesn't contribute to the proton
gradient so let me let me get at this
really quickly so this here complex 2
and this here is complex number one so
why is it that complex one can
contribute to the proton gradient but
complex 2 cannot so the reason why is
because here NADH was able to give its
electrons and its protons to FMN which
can accept protons and electrons and
then from there this this f MN which is
a protein complex in them the inner
membrane
of the mitochondria it can actually
accept those protons and then and
electrons of course and those protons
and electrons are then given up to the
iron sulfur cluster once it gets to the
iron sulfur cluster it can't accept the
protons so the protons get dumped into
the the intermembrane space side now
these iron sulfur clusters are typically
closer to the intermembrane space side
of the membrane so when deal when when
it can't accept the protons the protons
are just jumped right into the inner
membrane space however what's what's
going on with complex 2 well in complex
2 we go from succinate to fumarate and
we you know we reduce fa d to fadh2 once
we have this fadh2 what is fadh2 give it
to ha its protons and electrons to
notice it gives them straight to an iron
sulfur cluster so what's going on there
the fadh2 gives us electrons to the iron
sulfur cluster to reduce it and the iron
sulfur cluster has no problem with that
it definitely picks up those electrons
but what happens to these protons these
protons are not picked up so because
they're not picked up those protons
right the protons from them loops the
protons from fadh2 stay in the matrix of
the mitochondria so they do not
contribute to the proton gradient and
that is why their end up they end up
being worth less ATP than the NADH
because nadh has this protein that it
delivers the protons to before it the
iron sulfur cluster comes along so
theoretically if you could put some sort
of FMN like protein here right before so
the fadh2 can give its protons to that
before before the Vienna sulfur cluster
comes in theoretically you could
increase the amount of energy that and
fadh2 would be worth so maybe if you're
a bioengineer
and you're into that sort of thing keep
that in mind it'd be kind of cool the
rest of the chain really isn't isn't too
much different than what I just
right here just the idea that as you go
along to the right things increase in
reduction potential
so cytochrome a would would would get
reduced to cytochrome a reduced right by
taking the electrons from cytochrome C
then go further and further here we have
this copper ion here and then cytochrome
a 3 this is cytochrome C 1 I'm jumping
all over the place but really this is
something I would probably suggest that
you study on your own I just want to
give you an idea of how to sort of look
at this and read this the end here we're
going from oxygen and turning it into
water now the this water or this oxygen
picks up protons from the matrix so that
also contributes to the establishing of
the proton gradient so um one thing I
did want to comment on is like why is
this a chain why do we have a chain here
why so many redox reactions why doesn't
na da CH just give it electron straight
to oxygen well let's go back up here
notice that we had in these complexes
it's first complex negative 81
kilojoules then negative 13 and a
negative 34 the negative 110 what we're
doing here is basically we're releasing
a little bit of energy each time if we
had just one reaction if we just had one
redox reaction the cell could explode
all that differ all that energy just
being released who knows what kind of
damage it caused so basically why so
many redox reactions to prevent an
explosion really to prevent an explosion
a little mini explosion if you will in
the cell right you don't want a ton of
energy to be released at one time so
releasing the energy little by little
allows for the establishing of the
proton gradient which can then be used
to power the actual phosphorylation of
ATP which we'll talk about in the next
video thank you for watching